no look at you man you're looking for I
was gonna be here at the landowner so
but Brie and I'm super grateful to be
here really grateful no I talked to
Shawn power he city years I'm gonna
bring the lightning and the fire cuz you
guys did it at Coachella then you guys
hit that James Corden show what was it
like performing on that was amazing it
was really a blessing you know like to
me been with you know with a legend like
some poor it's truly a blessing I'm such
as an orator with him okay so we just
started planning he said you're dropping
another three months
what can you filling it we want to know
see that see what we're gonna do okay
we always we're we've got something
under with the are you've always got
something up your sleeve and up next for
you is you're collaborating with Chris
Brown and who else it was crisp and then
I got my god dude what do I fancy know
about that collaboration you about to
have another smash hit on your name boy
I need something you know when he can
keep going hates with summer why the per
se ask you about how you use it 15 years
so go tell why did why did you feel to
do that well you know I think we got to
represent the close turn the movement
and we're gonna show love you know to
the oh geez I open us you know open up
the doors for us you really I mean daddy
yankee Pro reggaeton on the map you're
carrying that torch and now so many
artists want to club with you and other
Latin artists but I got to know what's
the requirement what's the thing you're
looking for when an artist wants to be
an honorary member of the Latino game
embrace your culture that's it
jean-paul told us that all you have to
do with that distend attract to your new
you reply with the fire emojis fireman
whatever he does he's is amazing we're
also asking everyone on the carpet
tonight was your favorite place to
listen to Latin music is it the car is
it the club or the bedroom you know this
everywhere is such a violent
[Music]
[Applause]